Thomas Verrette, Director, Producer,
Editor: Just because how it may end
doesn't mean that the journey is not
valuable either. I think predictability
is a tough one to ask because
it's not all or nothing either.
Film Courage: Why are movies
so predictable these days?
Thomas: I think that there's a couple reasons.
One is the amount of content that is out now.
I think it gives us the impression
that movies are all predictable
when maybe it's just the movies that we're
watching that or the things that we think
or the movies that have the big releases if
that's the question are they predictable?
In that sense I think that's partially engineered
to just how the system works in a way I mean
those people are getting Oh let's do
this franchise. There's familiarity
and maybe the predictability of certain things.
Maybe that's what makes people comfortable. Maybe
that's what is drawing in them millions of dollars
from a studio executive's side that's putting up
100 or 200 million dollars to make that movie
they have to play those things safe in theory.
I don't know if that's true but I can at
least understand why they may be predictable.
Independent cinema and maybe some of the lower
tier budget types of films I think should
take those chances to do some differently
to not be predictable. I think that the
ones that are successful generally
are because they're not but maybe
there's also a lot to weed through to get there
too. I don't think that movies are all predictable
but I think that the ones that we’re barraged
with often are and as an independent filmmaker I'm
struggling with this even on my scent the side of
of it just how do you get a film out there so that
people want to watch it it versus people going to
the predictable movie is a challenge for all of us
really and yeah I mean I don't think that movies
are all predictable but I think there are reasons
why we think that they are and many of them
really are too and it's just kind of what we're
exposed to sometimes as well but you mentioned
that you've been watching movies that you hadn't
seen in many years because in some sense whether
there was a nostalgia there or you felt just the
storytelling was better yeah I think there's
both I mean but you can't make these movies
today without them think people would
think that they're predictable also I mean
what did I just watch the other day
the fugitive with Harrison Ford and
I love that movie is it a movie if you made
it exactly the same way today would people
it I don't know I really don't think so it's just
that I remember having a great experience watching
that as a kid and that's what but I do think it's
really well made and it and Tommy Lee Jones got an
academy reward and all this stuff and that movie
was also a movie I know was saved in the edit
too so that's some information I did not know when
I was seven and when I saw it but of course I'm I
i find those things fascinating and also some of
this is valuable maybe or I grew up in the age of
dvds and director's commentaries where you get
to listen to all this stuff none of that exists
really anymore and I kind of miss all of that
and I think that there's a disconnect between
the the the movies that we're watching
which just seem maybe cookie cutter as
you as you just as you were asking me about
earlier because of the sheer volume and all
the streamers and everything that's just they
have to put up new stuff every two days to keep
subscribers or whatever it is that they think
that but there's also no way for me to really
get involved with that that kind of personal
connection that I felt I had when I was younger
as a up-and-coming student in filmmaking and
things that where i've listened to every single
commentary and behind the scenes interview and
all that stuff and I just don't see it anymore
I'm not sure where and why that is it's just
the way films are distributed now I guess but
that's kind of where watching I know the fugitive
and and apollo 13. I have a lot of movies that
that I i just kind of gravitate towards dances
with wolves is another one where it's just
that familiarity to me it just brings me back to a
place where I'm reminded of what it felt as a kid
to be inspired by these things because sometimes
I get jaded by the industry I'm i'm working in
because it's just a constant it's it's my life
now and sometimes I need to take a step back and
just be why did I do this oh yeah it's because
of this moment in this movie when I was eight
are there things that filmmakers or writers
can do to make their films less predictable
well I think that depends on what the type of
movie is that you're talking about some movies
yeah you do want the here to win sometimes you
want to be taken on a ride sometimes you want to
the hero needs to die for the the for the theme to
come through or whatever what I mean there's all
sorts of different reasons and predictability
is that's also sometimes a little bit just
like subjective really I mean oh so you
knew that the guy was gonna catch the girl
two minutes before is that predictable or is it or
or is it that you knew that the that maximus was
gonna die at the end of gladiator what I mean
yeah but of course but he had to have died to
for that story to have it's it's potency and and
kind of emotional weight and but yeah just because
how it may end doesn't mean that the journey is
not valuable either so I think predictability
is a tough one to to ask because it's
not all or nothing either for me at least
I'm okay with going down a journey that
I may have an idea of how it might end
but how I got there might change whether I thought
it was predictable or not what I mean of course
it's our job to take the audience on a ride as
filmmakers as writers as editors as directors
and how we can ensure that I think it really
kind of starts in the script honestly and
sometimes you're working on something that
you don't have any say and all that but if
you're if you are a screenwriter I think
there's a balance between getting paid
to write something versus what you're writing to
get noticed right everybody from my understanding
in this industry is knock my socks off with your
spec script but then that will get you hired
and then they're going to make you write it
this and this and this because of x, y and z
whatever that is so there's an aspect of the
business that's just part of that process.